was aus sicht einiger sozusagen der
beginn ihres abwärtstrends war nämlich
das lachen in der flut das schauen wir
uns noch einmal an wie das auslegen die
vieles verloren haben die große verluste
erlitten haben
dass ihnen hilfe zuteil werden soll
und diese hilfe die zugesagt in der
debatte die wir dann erlebt haben also
das lachen sie standen dort hinter frank
walter steinmeier hat eine rede gehalten
was ich mich gefragt habe worüber haben
sie da nicht gelacht als
jemand hat eine blöde bemerkungen
darüber habe ich gedacht das war die
leute merken ich will aber ich will das
gar nicht vertiefen aber es ist doch
schreien ich finde es nicht spannend
weil es war unpassend es war unpassend
ich habe nicht gehört was der
bundespräsident sprach der stadt
bestimmt also jetzt danach ist ihr
lachen sogar ein kruse war wie weit wir
haben das alle dahinter nicht gehört
deshalb
hat das gar nicht auf die worte des
bundespräsidenten reagiert
nicht ich selbst wie sehr hat eine blöde
bemerkung gemacht ich habe darauf
reagiert es war falsch das hat mich
geärgert ich habe wenige stunden später
gesagt
ich bedaure dass ich entschuldige mich
dafür
aber ich kann es ja auch nicht mehr
ungeschehen machen wir nur wenn sie sich
das vorstellen sie sind da tag und nacht
in der flut unterwegs und in diesem
entsetzlichen traurigen momenten
schildern einen leute ja manche leute
beginnen zu weinen die nimmt man dann
nämlich in den arm und versucht sie zu
trösten andere machen selbst mitten in
der flut noch eine launige bemerkung das
ist auch noch gehören zu denjenigen ja
ich mache die nicht ich höre zu aber ich
sehe wie die menschen reagieren und
jeder geht mit solchen ereignissen
anders um und dennoch muss jemand wie
ich der ministerpräsident ist da anders
reagieren das war falsch und dabei
bleibt war das der beginn des abwärts
das weiß ich nicht es war jedenfalls
nicht toll
[Musik]